今日  セカンドチャンヌーの動画は
あのね  こういうね   カメラ系の紹介は  なんか
別に凄い   カメラってね？   その、 ユーチューブをやるうえで 大事だからね？
メインチャンネルで　揚げても良いと思ったんです　けども
今回に関しては　サブでもいいかな？と思いました
今回買って来たのはこちら！
ソニー・α（アルファー）・５１００（ごせんひゃく）
と言う事でですね
ミラーレス、一眼ですか？　何でいうんですか？
あの、僕が昔までね、ずっとずっと最近も…使ってたやつ
ああ  充電も出来なんだ。  今ずっと充電してたんですけど、  もう電池が  ３２%っ て書いてある
こちらの　ＮＥＸ５Ｒ…あー待って　これメインチャンエルで出そうかな？
はい、 と言う訳で ﾁｮｯﾄ なんか
コイツを見た瞬間　ウルッと来てしまったので
メインです！
わー、 なんかなー
不思議な気分ですね　ﾁｮｯﾄね・・・
ヤバい、　なんか泣けてきた
まって　落ち着いて話しますね？
もうトシなのかな？　涙もろいんだけど？
はい、こちらの　ＮＥＸ５Ｒ　ですね
何時からだっけなぁ
何で泣いてんの？
ああ、あった、あった、これか！
２年前ですね。　わ、もう懐かしい
ネックス　じゃねえ、　エヌイーエックス　だわ
いきなり　ディス　んだし
はい、という感じでですねぇ
２年前かな？　今見た動画が　２年前の　動画なんですけど
ずっとね、ユーチューブ始めた時に
その・・・　すごい安っぽいビデオカメラで
ずっと撮ってて・・・  それでまあ  見て下さる方が増えて  その
そろそろ   新しいカメラ   買おうかなって  ゆって   初めて買ったのが
２年前の何時だ？　２０１３年の１月ですね
２年前のお正月とかかな？　お正月に買ったのかな？
お正月にこの  ＮＥＸ５Ｒ  と言うカメラを買ったんですけども
ホントに このカメラには、  感謝しきれないほど   色んな物を
あの、色々思い出があります。
初めて買ったこの、 一眼の美しさって言うんですか、 綺麗さに惚れて、 凄い大切に使ってて
ＳＤカードも  開けすぎて、 ここに  こんな   ヒビが  入っちゃったり
そろそろ限界が来たっという事で　って言う事を　思い出して、今泣いてます！
いや、ほんとにねぇ　こんなにユーチューブと　言うものが続く事になるとは　思わなかったし
このカメラ一台で　僕はここまで来たと言っても　過言では無いぐらいね？　ここまで一緒に歩んできたカメラです。
イギリスに僕、　半年間留学に行ってて、　その留学中にもこれを持って　行ったんですけども
俺は壊してないｿﾞ？　俺は壊さないけど、　あの、　たくみがね？
僕の友達のたくみがね、イギリスに来てて一緒に遊んでた時に、俺が持ってて、
で、たくみが、　こう…手を振りおろした瞬間に、　このカメラにガツンと　当たってレンズだけ壊れたってゆう
あのぉ、　なんかしょっぱい思い出とかもあります。
取りあえずね、　僕にとっては大切でした、　あの、　ＮＥＸ５Ｒ　って言うカメラは
それからね、 ＮＸ５  Ｔとか、  ＮＥＸ６なんとか　 とか　  色々出てて
自撮りできる様に　こっち向いてる　カメラってゆうのを　初めて買って、　ｽｺﾞいテンションが上がった、　当時を思い出します
１年前の　動画のほぼすべてが　このカメラで撮って
イギリス留学中の  半年間も  このカメラを日本から あっちに持ってって  ずっとコイツと動画を撮って
何かある時も　全部このカメラで　色々撮って来て
レンズも  もう おかしくなっちゃって      遅いんです  反応が  回しても
そうでもねぇや。　充電が出来なくなるってゆう現象ですね。
エラーが出て、　たまに繋がんない時が最近しょっちゅうあって
今だともう　ほぼ繋げなくて充電も　出来ないってゆう状態です
も、もう、色んなもの撮り過ぎててねぇ  思い出が ありすぎるんですよね
かと言って 何かホント 色んな所が 壊れてて 修理を出しても  修理を出すこと 自体が ちょっと お金的に 勿体ないんで
今回別のカメラに・・・　替わる事になりました
こっちはもうね、正直いいよ、取りあえず替わるんで、こっちだよね、今日のメインはこっちですよ
取りあえずカメラが替わります
アルファの、５１００
この子のね？　遠い親戚みたいなもんなんで、
そんなに 見た目は 変わんないです・・・ほら
見た目も レンズも 同じなんで、 そんなに性能的には…
こっちの方が はるかに 早いですけど、 フォーカスとかは
最近見出した人は ﾁｮｯﾄ わかんないと 思うんですけども
僕の動画はホントに
もう、このカメラ買った時かな？
２年前ぐらいから見てる人、メチャクチャもう愛用してて
無駄にカッコつけて  写真撮って  それでこうなんかスライドショー   みたいな 動画も出してたし
これを買ってから・・・
僕の、なんか  ｙｏｕｔｕｂｅ  に対する 気持ちってのが
遥かに切り替わってたって言う　きっかけです
コイツが居ないと 僕はもう多分  ｙｏｕｔｕｂｅ  やってなかった ぐらいだと思います
すごい、僕にとっては貴重な物でした
ホントに もう多分 限界まで ガタが 来てるんですよ
本当にね、色んな事が あった、 このカメラらを使ってる時に
壊れることも有ったし、イギリスも一緒に行ったし、
単焦点レンズっていうね？綺麗にボケるレンズがあるんですけど、そういうレンズを付けてね？
こうなんか、すげーすげーっとかはしゃいでみたりね？
黒にすればよかった。
白だし女っぽいし、２０分くらい撮ったら 熱暴走して 止まるし
ＳＤカードないと保存も出来ないし
でも　大切な・・・物です
ひょっとしたら人生で一番大事なものかもしれないな
僕の  ｙｏｕｔｕｂｅ  の原点は このカメラでした
この カメラから もう  全てが変わった、 って言うね・・・そういう感じで ございますよ。
こんな感じか･･･うん、綺麗、きれい
でもな、なんかやっぱ違うんだよな
俺、おれ・・・なんでカメラに泣いてんの？
誰からもらった 訳でもなく自分で買ったカメラ  なんですけど
お別れしてちょっと、新しいモデルに進化します！
これからね、この新しいのと　動画とって行ければいいなと、思っております。
また、次回の動画でお会いしましょう
じゃあな~
おやすみ~